there we go
hey guys how you doing this week like
most week was very dull but I actually
got to hang out with somebody who I had
not hung out in a very very long time
actually it wasn't just one person it
was two people and they actually come
together as a package because they are a
married couple now if you guys don't
know who this is
she is an amazing musician on YouTube
when she yes it was Claire Chun and her
husband Dan Fisher I'm gonna slap you in
public
Oh mm-hmm you're not even wait I
actually got to know Dan before I got to
know Claire because Dan when he first
came here from Seattle I actually housed
him in my place when he didn't have a
place to live and then to most people
surprised even though you look at him
you may think that he's a white boy he's
actually half Korean half white he just
happens to you know the Koreans I just
got the [ __ ] beat out of him Oh
but shortly after Dan was making the
transition from Seattle to over here we
decided to move in together at this
apartment off of Wilshire and k-town and
if you guys want to know what Dan does
dan is a videographer he does amazing
work and of course being a videographer
he has a lot of cool toys like we were
messing with this drone that he had
earlier I know a lot of you girls don't
give a [ __ ] but who cares [ __ ] was cool
I got a girlfriend al khair she don't
think it's cool either but whatever you
with me now you stuck forever [ __ ] but
we all decide to meet up and have dinner
at this Korean barbecue joint called
Stone grill it's one of my favorite
all-you-can-eat places they have a crap
ton of meat selections it always tastes
superb umm and on top of that they got
shabu shabu on the side and yes that's
also all-you-can-eat [ __ ] BBQ
was like one of those quintessential
things that you always do with the
Korean friends if you have a Korean
friend they didn't take you get that
means they really don't like you this
[ __ ] [ __ ] they like the
Hamburglar you should realize that a lot
of the friends that I have are just as
weird as I am or maybe even a little
more odd weird is definitely cool with
me but sometimes she's she's the oddball
like I look into her eyes and I see a
couple of gum balls just floating just
do it go to mad funny enough the first
time I met Clara was actually because we
did a video together called heart to
heart a heart to heart with a series
that I started where I wanted to
interview different youtubers and uh it
was very natural it didn't give a lot of
pressure to people who didn't act and so
they could just be themselves and I
would just create the comedy around them
so the heart-to-heart episode that we
did there was a part where I kind of
break in to her house and while I'm
going through the window I told her she
could freestyle any type of insults that
she wants and the first thing that comes
out this bitch's mouth is I was so taken
aback almost I said what I just met you
how you gonna call me fat but you don't
when you come out with insults like that
and you can laugh about it that's like
definitely a friendship that you want to
keep for the [ __ ] he's such an amazing
talent when it comes to a lot of YouTube
musicians like when I hear that make
their originals it doesn't move me a lot
but there was this one song that Clara
made called fish that people didn't know
what the meaning was it was about a
husband and Fisher but I heard it it's
tough you know it lightweight maybe tear
up a little bell Friday but for me
that's what makes a really good musician
and that's what really good music is
they can take their thoughts and their
emotions and kind of put us into a world
that we really aren't
privy to but the moment they take those
emotions and thoughts into song we
suddenly connect with it and that's why
Claire is such a great musician because
when I listen to that song I was like I
want to be matte finish but I genuinely
believe there is a huge difference
between music that is popular and that
music that's going to last why do you
think I listen to Brightman I so much
I specifically listen to Brightman night
because he came around right when I got
dumped by my very first girlfriend and I
want to die do my ever cross your mind
but it was great hanging out with the
old crew because man like it's amazing
how much things have changed in one year
Dan and Edie actually met me when I was
broke his [ __ ] like the apartment that I
lived in but my rooms just had a bed a
utility shelf this this desk I got at
Walmart and and my computer that I was
editing off of and that's about it
then an edit stuck around me since I was
nobody and I was like 40 pounds heavier
than I was now so you know you stuck
with me for life [ __ ] being around them
too is also another reminder that how
much I've grown too because back in the
day my friend choices were absolutely
poor it was always about people that
could make me look cool or do something
for me but when you choose to be around
people who are genuinely good-hearted
people they start to reflect and grow
upon you too so cream barbecue brings
people together
so this is
the searchers
you